merci beaucoup d'être là monsieur
charles rozoy est ce que notre chaîne
d'approvisionnement alimentaire peut
faire face à ce pic de consommation à
cette frénésie laquelle on observerait
en ce moment la réponse est oui on
regarde les photos les vidéos je suis
pas certain que tout le monde le sait il
faut avoir confiance les chaînes
d'approvisionnement
depuis quelques années plusieurs détails
un distributeur qui ont investi
énormément logistique
on a affaire à des chaînes intelligente
flexible et quelque chose comme ça
arrive là on est prêt pour on a affaire
à un virus un faucon prend que c'est un
virus et non pour un tremblement terre
aux désastres naturels ou quelque chose
quelle est la différence pour les
chaînes d'approvisionnement
c'est le temps ça veut dire qu'on a le
temps de se préparer on a le temps que
le consommateur de faire des réserves y
a pas d'urgence à le faire en 24 heures
en amont il ya la transformation qui se
prépare parce conçu par exemple on
fabrique la soupe d'ailleurs kembo
doivent annoncer que la compagnie
augmentait la cadence au niveau de la
production
il y avait quelques semaines on a
anticipé cette hausse l'a donc en
transformation on ne remplit les
entrepôts en distribution
évidemment on anticipait le choc est si
au niveau national ce qui passe qui avec
le vc qu'on a vu
on a vu l'étalement de la panique
d'ouest en est
on a vu vancouver la kangoo tannique
d'alberta paniquée la cinquième semaine
passée depuis deux trois jours c'est
toronto l'ontario est maintenant en fait
tous à rattraper québec aujourd'hui même
on le voit là la télévision c'est
incroyable vous dites que les chaînes
d'approvisionnement sont c'est bien
planifié il ya des stocks pour répondre
à la demande mais on entend souvent ça
de plus en plus et de la distribution
juste à temps pour avoir des produits
frais le plus près possible
est-ce que les épiceries les détaillants
ont quand même des stocks on peut tenir
combien de temps par exemple c'est ça
les gens pensent il faut il faut de
l'inventaire sur place
et puis quand ça fonctionne c'est que
les sculpteurs vont établir de leurs
règles avec leurs fournisseurs
donc on va entreposer avec des entrepôts
intelligent un peu partout on va avoir
des termes particuliers avec certains
fournisseurs et on veut pas
nécessairement être exclusif avec un
fond de 100 non plus il ya dix quinze
vingt ans on s'entendait avec un
fournisseur de table par exemple
et puis s'ils se font ça va être en
rupture de stock mais on n'avait pas
avancé puis comme ça que ça fonctionne
l'on voit on va négocier avec plusieurs
fournisseurs alors si mal le parquet
chez avec un fournisseur avec un don
c'est quoi à part la nourriture qu'on
consomme ici qui produite ici la part qu
on importe parce qu'on est quand même
dépendant là entre autres pour les
produits frais en fait c'est tara ci de
l'année la mi mars ses caves on n'est
pas quand même pas mal plus que je sais
pas moi juillet-août avoue même
septembre ça c'est clair mais ça dépend
de quelqu'un lyon garde dans les fruits
des légumes
on est très dépendante des importations
et on s'entend donc s'il ya quelque
chose qui se passe avec la frontière
willow américaine si ce qui m'inquiète
le plus pour monsieur legault en dix ans
il y aura pas de problème ou de
l'approvisionnement mais le gros mais
c'est la frontière si par exemple le
grand américain décide de bloquer le
fermer cette frontière là qui est assez
importante
là on parle de nos scénarios le scénario
possiblement catastrophique pour les
fruits et légumes pour plusieurs
produits parce que les réseaux ce2 ont
mieux développés sont plus efficaces
même si les produits proviennent pas des
états unis elles peuvent venait
d'ailleurs et en plus on une économie
ouverte les ingrédients passe du nord au
sud au nord
ça pourrait vraiment compliqué le choc
et donc on dans ce scénario là on en est
pas encore mais dans ce scénario là ça
voudrait dire quoi moins de produits
disponibles
est ce qu'une hausse des prix ça se peut
également quand on a de la difficulté à
avoir accès à ces ressources est
et qu'il est d'offre et de demande est
ce que ça peut monter les prix mais ce
qu'il faut pas du pétrole quand on parle
même plus et ainsi se tourner qu'avec la
guerre depuis actuelle qui prévaut entre
la russie puis on en a pas parlé
beaucoup cette semaine par à cause du
caviste 19 mai le gros sujet sur bhv et
puis surtout alberto si le pétrole le
pétrole et prochain et les gens s'en
sont en fait on s'en rend compte
lorsqu'on fait le plein ou la station
d'essence et ça ça fait en sorte que
notre coût de transport diminue et donc
moins de pression sur les distributeurs
ça n'a pas de sens si les prix vont
coûter moins cher le d'or cannes a dit
ah ben oui énormément quat'sous depuis
quatre jours donc pour les prix des
aliments ce sont deux éléments qui
s'annulent enquête a révolutionné de la
crise du choix oui on avait vu des prix
s'était montée du dollar que ce à cause
des crues du fleuve la baisse soudaine
du dollar canadien soit un mot on sent
vauvert là donc
et puis en masse avril on importe est
normal faisait des lieux donc je vous
entends pour les fruits et légumes frais
vous prévoyez vous pensez que c'est
possible qu'ils aient une augmentation
des prix dans les prochaines semaines
c'est parce que c'est passé mais s'il
part en raison du fait que les dts
veulent prendre avantage d'une demande
plus robuste veulent prendre avantage du
compte est que dans lequel on vit de
flins ce n'est pas du tout surtout avec
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui le bonne
chance à des terres qui veut profiter de
l'occasion oui bon sens ce serait plutôt
mal vu je vais vous emmener ailleurs
avant que constater il ya des
consommateurs en ce moment oui qui se
ruent vers les supermarchés mais avec
cette menace du cornât virus peut-être
il y en a plusieurs qui aimerait bien ne
pas y aller et l'on pense à l'achat en
ligne
les détaillants ont mis sur pied ces
programmes là il ya quelques mois mais
n'est pas une grande portion des
consommateurs qui
il utilise encore est ce que ça pourrait
augmenter à ce que les détaillants ont
la capacité de migrer encore plus vers
la livraison de l'épicerie en ligne par
exemple
alibaba 2003 le stress le stress permis
alibaba devenir le géant du commerce et
des conseillers aujourd'hui moi je les
aperçois qu on pourrait vous revoir ce
scénario là maintenant avec kobe 19
c'est certain que les gens vont s'ils ne
veulent pas s'exposer à d'autres
personnes pourraient contaminer ce
certain que l'économie grecque devient
intéressant comme comme avenue et je me
sens prêt pour faire face à cette
demande qui pourrait être accrue
certains détails poteau ce l'effet
amazon faire en sorte que on a un
vêtement dans la parade tout le monde
puis 1 à 2 au bout d'eux on investit
dans le commerce berne éthiques
mais c'est pas tout le monde qui est
prêt moi je peux raconter 3 4 qui sont
prêts on est le reste suit
bon cela dit à partir de maintenant si
on est de méfiance envers les
déplacements à l'épicerie est ce qu'on
doit avoir une méfiance envers la
salubrité des aliments est ce qui a des
vues des mesures par exemple sont
dictées par les autorités alimentaire
bonne question
bonjour j'aimerais c'est que la chasse
canadienne soit plus proactive en
informer publique moi je reçois des
questions sur la dessus la réponse est
non je penserais pas il ya toujours un
risque à tout le il pourrait avoir
continuation mais il faut bien les
comprendre faut bien comme et qui sert
et cela est à chaque fois qu'une crise
comme ça on entend rarement lagence
quinzaine d'espèces aux aliments parce
qu'on laisse toute la place à l' agence
de la santé publique pour les humains -
c'est correct mais pour les allemands il
faut informer les canadiens bon monsieur
charlebois la question qui tue est ce
qu'on stocke du paquet toi c'est pas de
ça
qu'est ce qu'on achète à l'épicerie la
france manque pas un gros ce qu'il faut
chez en temps normal il faut quand même
des provisions pour 400 g de produit
sèche par sauf ce genre de choses là
donc une variété
de protéines de carbohydrates aussi
c'est important dans le surgelé les
fruits et légumes parce que si par
exemple pendant depuis mais il faut
quand même aller chercher des vitamines
là et on peut le garder ce pendant six
mois au moins
tant mieux hello lourd surtout les x
award ou à la maison de fautes en avance
y ait quelque chose qui pense avec le
système d'aqueduc
quand même quelque chose donc en gros
c'est ça est un peu papier toilette mais
pourquoi une jauge est plus que logique
ce qui se passe monsieur charlebois les
gens arrivent devant des tables est vide
et c'est là où se déclenche l'urgence
d'achèvement déclencheur c'est que une
tablette de papier toit se vide
rapidement visuellement on voit la table
est vide on se dit oh mon dieu on va
manquer faut en acheter
c'est prendre un peu ce qui se passe
aussi évidemment le ps toit pour
plusieurs personnes une source de
réconfort
évidemment ici on est en baisse c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle
nouveau mais ya pas lieu à paniquer il
faut il faut il faut planifier mais pas
paniquer bon alors sur ces mots 5
on vous laisse merci pour vos
explications merci